Selena Gomez's shark tank dreams have
finally come true I just feel really
blessed to have this opportunity the
singer's pal Connor Franklin
instagrammed a few pics of Selena and
their friends Caroline and Aaron
visiting the set of the hit show in the
snap Selena can be seen smiling
alongside the investors Marc Kevin
Laurie Barbara and Robert I'm very
honored Selena kept it cute and cash for
the outing rocking a white pin striped
blouse blue jeans and some hoop earrings
Connor captioned the series of picks
quote deep in the tank best day ever
getting to do things that I'm passionate
about with the people that I love but
Selena and her friends weren't the only
ones excited about the visit to set the
investors were too robert shared this
pic with selena writing guests who made
it into the tank back in July Selena
explained that her BFFs surprised her
for her birthday revealing they would be
taking her to visit the show set her
pals even had Marc send along a sweet
message
needless to say Selena was pretty stoked
about the present
Selena captioned this clip on Instagram
quote not many of you know but I am
obsessed with Shark Tank two of my best
friends nailed my gift but she isn't the
first celeb to visit the tank I always
invest in the jockey not the horse
Ashton Kutcher Bethenny Frankel and Alex
Rodriguez have all been guest sharks on
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]